in keeping with tonight's nostalgia
theme I think we should pause for a
moment and think back all the way to the
beginning of this show
screen actors saw signs of an ominous
trend in film casting last year when
several writers put on makeup Norman
Mailer and ragtime Fay Keenan and rich
and famous year's echoes in ski and
George Clinton and reds all are now
eligible for consideration as best
writer in the supporting role happily
there is no such category
more happily the author of the current
novel pinball last year adapted his
bestseller being there to the screen is
here to present writing Awards the
distinguished author and part-time actor
years--a Kaczynski
my experience as an actor has taught me
the importance of a writer
we who act also much to those of us who
write the Bible tells us that in the
beginning was the world when the
universe was in complete disorder
Moses was called to the mountain a
warning bolt of lightning an overture of
thunder the skies parted and a mighty
hand reached down to give Moses the
stone tablets that was the first script
some critics thought it was over
produced for just ten lines but but by
following it
mankind restored order out of disorder
if succeeding generations had stuck to
that original script instead of
ad-libbing around it so much this would
be a better world to live in
the original script nominated this year
as Best Screenplay written directly for
the screen absence of malice by Kurt
latke art owned by Steve Gordon Atlantic
City by John ware
Charaka fire by codeine Whelan
and Red's by Warren Beatty and Trevor
Griffin
I admire all of you and the winner is
Colleen Whelan
what you've done for the British film
industry I just like to thank David
Puttnam for having the wisdom to ask me
to write it in the first place
Hugh Hudson for respecting me and my
script which is a very hard thing to
find in our businesses you know all the
actors for getting fit enough to appear
like Olympic athletes and two British
television where I learned my craft I'd
like to finish with a word of warning
you may have started something the
British are coming